ya que sabemos que la integral definida
nos va a ayudar a calcular el área entre
dos curvas o bajo dos curvas entonces
voy a utilizar la misma noción para
enseñarles que los volúmenes de los
sólidos de revolución tienen el mismo
principio que es lo que quiero decir
bueno para esto voy a utilizar un par de
ejemplos permítanme empezar con una
función un poco sencilla voy a tomar
este que sean viaje de las 'íes' y ahora
voy a tomar a este como un viaje de las
equis muy bien y ahora sobre este plano
cartesiano lo que voy a hacer es dibujar
una función esta función va a ser la
función que igual a raíz de x entonces
permítanme dibujar la tomemos el color
verde y vamos a hacer la gráfica
bien aquí está no no no no está
graficando me gusta está un poco para
chorradas voy a intentar hacer una
gráfica más bonita a ver de aquí hasta
acá muy bien esta gráfica me gusta más
se parece más a mi función es x igual a
la raíz de x este es mi eje de las x
este es mi eje de las 10 y cuando yo
veía la noción de integral les decía que
si quería el área bajo la curva de esta
función pero de un punto a a un punto b
entonces hacíamos lo siguiente primero
tenemos que agarrar los puntos entonces
voy a suponer que este es mi punto a y
este aquí hacen un punto ver y lo que yo
quería era el área abajo de la curva del
punto a al punto b así que hagamos una
línea de a no pero de otro color porque
no quiero que se confunda y una línea
ave pero hijo de mezclilla está muy
torcida eso ya merece un poco torcido y
estas líneas están torcidas pero ya
quedó entonces lo que yo quería era el
área que había abajo de mi curva del
punto a al punto b lo que hacía era
hacer rectángulos muchos rectángulos
pequeños que tuvieran de base d
y de altura que tuviera fx fx si x era
el punto que estaba entre de x bien y
entonces si yo hacía un montón de estos
rectángulos los sumaba a todos tenía la
noción de integral la integral yo decía
que el integral de a que era mi índice
inferior a b que era mil veces superior
de fx era el área de abajo de la curva
muy bien entonces ya tengo yo una noción
de que la suma de muchos rectángulos me
daba la integral de bdf de x de x si
ustedes aprendieron está integrado como
robot sería muy bueno que repasarán otra
vez estas notas porque después a la
mente muchas trabas y en muchos
problemas por no saber bien la noción de
integral además recuerden que aprenderse
las cosas con una forma monótona nunca
sirve en matemáticas pero bueno ahora mi
idea es tener esta función de fx y
hacerla girar alrededor del eje de las x
para esto voy a utilizar toda su
imaginación y que visualicen qué es lo
que está pasando
voy a intentar dibujar nos vamos
si puedo dibujar aquí en la computadora
y se han servido mis clases de dibujo
es como una como un recipiente es algo
muy pareció un recipiente donde estás la
boca del recipiente es como un vaso
acostado con una taza acostado y este es
un volumen entonces voy a poner un poco
de sombras para que parezca un volumen y
por aquí va a estar el eje de las diez y
por aquí el eje de las equis bueno lo
voy a poner con verde para que no se
confundan por aquí el eje de las equis y
por el eje leyes muy bien si yo giro
esta función alrededor del eje de las x
lo que obtengo es una taza acostada
ahora voy a dibujar una flecha y esta
flecha me indica el sentido en el que
está girando mi función pero realmente
yo lo que quería era mi sólido de
revolución que me sale al girar esta
función del punto a al punto b como se
quisiera solamente una rebanada o un
pedazo de mi caso el original
voy a intentar dibujarlo y a veces nos
queda un poco más claro así que a ver
intentemos otra vez clases de dibujo voy
a intentar hacer hacer una línea
no me gusta esta línea no va a ser lo
que yo quiero voy a borrarla bien lo que
intentemos hacerla de un color distinto
esta va a ser mi mi apertura mayor y voy
a sombrear la para que parezca más real
y voy a hacer el sólido de una vez y me
necesito otro círculo en la parte
inferior un circulo más pequeño se dan
cuenta mi función va decreciendo este
círculo corresponde a yo lo voy a
dibujar aquí mi eje de las x bien por
aquí va justo en medio va a medir de las
equis y ahora también necesito mi eje de
las más bien aquí tengo que puntear mi
eje de las x hacia adentro así les va a
dar una percepción de que está adentro
punteado y aquí está mi otra mi otro
círculo mi otra boca de mi de mi parte
de mi cazuela y aquí está el punto a muy
bien ya tengo el punto b y el punto a a
y él me da que de las x que se sigue se
sigue se sigue y aquí se toca con el eje
de las 10 muy bien ya pasamos la parte
más difícil que era la parte de
visualización
también con color morado voy a hacer
punteado todo mi sólido como realmente
me tendría que quedar mi sólido me
tendría que quedar si no fuera de ave si
fuera un sólido total si fuera nuestra
cazuela que teníamos del lado derecho
sería esta cazuela de aquí y en este
momento es hora de hacer la analogía con
el sonido de revolución y la integral si
nosotros giramos mi función alrededor
del eje de las x entonces bueno primero
recuerda que cada rectángulo de estos al
sumarlos completamente nos daba la
noción completa de integral esto no
tiene que olvidar la suma de todos estos
rectángulos nos da la noción de integral
muy bien ahora imagínense qué va a pasar
si nosotros vamos a hacer girar cada uno
de estos rectángulos tengan imaginación
y visualicen a un montón de rectángulos
girando alrededor del eje de las equis
voy a tomar un rectángulo base esta va a
ser mi rectángulo y entonces de ancho
tiene de equis y de altura lo voy a
poner de color verde para que se vea
mejor y de altura tenía efe de x mi
altura era fx de este rectángulo
entonces lo voy a notar aquí con color
amarillo de aquí acá la altura es f de x
bien ahora voy a intentar hacerles un
pequeño dibujo acerca de cómo quedaría
este rectángulo al girar alrededor del
quedase x va a quedar con un pequeño
disco se dan cuenta es un disco muy
delgado entonces voy a decir que esta es
es mi base del disco se borró estás
vivas el disco bien y tiene una pequeña
anchura y entonces esta es mi
otra cara del disco y justo aquí está el
centro del disco bien entonces que
sabemos de este disco bueno lo que yo sé
es que tiene una altura qué altura tiene
este disco este disco tiene altura pues
fx esta altura es fx y es lo que va a
girar alrededor del eje de las x
entonces de aquí a acá pues va a ser
también de fede x bien entonces tiene de
altura f x y cuánto tiene de ancho pues
esta parte si está de aquí es lo que
tenía de ancho mi disco que es de x
entonces mi disco tiene de ancho de x y
de una altura más bien de un radio efe
de x pero ahora la pregunta va a ser
cuál es el volumen de este disco pues el
volumen de este disco tiene que ver con
el área de la parte superior de este
disco y el ancho de este disco pero
quieres el área de este disco a ver pues
va a ser ping por radio al cuadrado es
el área de un círculo están de acuerdo
pero que hace el radio el radio era fx
habíamos dicho que fx era el radio de
este disco entonces voy a sustituir el
área es igual a pi
el radio que s fx entonces fx elevado
todo al cuadrado bien y si ya tengo el
área de este círculo y además tengo que
el ancho vale de x entonces yo ya puedo
saber cuál es el volumen del disco el
volumen del disco entonces lo voy a
escribir
de este lado va a ser igual a quien
volumen es igual a pi por radio al
cuadrado por el ancho o sea pi por fx
elevado al cuadrado por el ancho del
disco pero el ancho del disco es de x
están de acuerdo entonces voy a
multiplicar no todo por de x
muy bien este es el volumen de uno de
mis discos pero realmente yo tengo
muchos discos girando entonces al menos
ya es el volumen de uno de ellos pero el
cuento no acaba aquí yo lo que quiero es
el volumen de todo mi mi parte de la
cazuela que está entre a y b entonces
imagínense que voy a agarrar cada uno de
estos discos y voy a tener que sumar
entonces todos estos discos voy a tener
que sumar una infinidad de discos con la
suma infinita por cada uno de los discos
entonces si el volumen es este de un
disco pues yo ya puedo tener la noción
de una suma infinita porque la suma
infinita es la integral entonces si yo
ya sé que el volumen de uno de ellos es
este entonces ya que el volumen de toda
mi parte de mi cazuela mismo no va a ser
la integral de ave porque mi cazuela
está limitada por a y por ver de quién
pues el volumen de cada uno de los
discos o sea de pi por fx elevado al
cuadrado por de x
bien ya tengo construido por fin el
volumen de toda mi cazuela que me sale
al girar yo mi función alrededor del eje
de las equis y el volumen estaba
relacionado con una integral que tenía
que ver con efe de x con la anchura y
además con pi es muy importante que
ustedes no se memorizan esto como robots
analicen de dónde salió cada parte de
esta construcción de esta integral en el
siguiente vídeo voy a ver una aplicación
a la vida real hasta luego